Okay, you can't call them a rival podcast because they put out like two episodes. It's a juicy content here. Bryce, is there anything else you'd like to say about JF while we're on the topic? I'm sure TLB hit is very good. They have produced four episodes. It's not nice to dunk this hard. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 72 recorded on March 27 2022. My name is Connor and today today with my co-host Bryce, we conduct a live C++ interview family feud style. Are you ready? No, I am not ready. All right. Episode 72 has begun.
好吧，你不能叫他们竞争播客，因为他们只出了大概两集。这里的内容很精彩。布莱斯，趁我们在聊这个，你还有什么想对JF说的吗？我确信TLB的点击量会很好。他们已经制作了四集。这样下狠手不太好。欢迎来到ADSP播客第72期，录制于2022年3月27日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起，以“家庭问答”的风格进行了一场直播C++面试。准备好了吗？不，我还没准备好。好的。第72期开始了。
And on today's episode of ADSP, the podcast fail Connor's interview question. Bryce is going to answer a C++ interview question that I legitimately, we could call this the NVIDIA, the unofficial NVIDIA C++ interview question because it's only ever been asked once by me and it might have been a bad question, but hey, clickbait, here we go. We should clarify because I just sent an email about this last week asking the teams that I work with to, you know, asking them to not do whiteboard questions anymore.
在今天的ADSP播客中，康纳的面试题失败了。布莱斯将回答一个我合法提出的C++面试题，我们甚至可以称之为“英伟达，非官方英伟达C++面试题”，因为它只被我问过一次，而且可能是一个糟糕的问题，但嘿，点击诱饵，我们开始吧。我们应该澄清一下，因为我上周刚刚发了一封邮件，要求我合作的团队，你知道的，要求他们不要再出白板题了。
We will record a separate episode to follow this episode up, which is a conversation about the fact that we probably shouldn't do whiteboard questions anymore. So that's if you're thinking, oh, man. But in this particular case, when you use this interview question, it was for somebody that was a new college grad or intern, and you sort of gave them the option of do you want to just talk about your resume or do you want to do an interview question? Well, no, false. We talked about just C++ stuff, and this candidate was extremely enthusiastic
我们将录制另一集来跟进这一集，内容是关于我们可能不应该再出白板题的讨论。所以如果你在想，天哪。但在这种特殊情况下，当你使用这道面试题时，它是给应届毕业生或实习生的，你某种程度上给了他们一个选项：你是想只聊聊你的简历，还是想做一道面试题？好吧，不，不对。我们只聊了C++相关的内容，这位候选人非常热情
and passionate. So we just talked about C++ stuff, you know, favorite algorithms, projects they'd work on, resume stuff for the first 20, 30 minutes of the interview. And then I switched to a technical question and then gave them the option to either just talk about it. They had a whiteboard behind them. And I said, or you can whiteboard it if you want, or we can open up a Godbolt if you would prefer to have a compiler. So I have zero preference. I mean, I know I would want Godbolt
且充满激情。所以在面试的前20到30分钟，我们只聊了C++相关的东西，比如喜欢的算法、做过的项目、简历相关的内容。然后我切换到一个技术问题，接着给他们两个选项：要么直接讨论它，他们身后有一个白板，我说：“或者如果你愿意，可以在白板上写，如果我们更喜欢编译器，也可以打开Godbolt。”所以我完全没有偏好。我的意思是，我知道我会想要Godbolt
because I like having a compiler telling me what I'm doing wrong. But like it was up to the candidate what they wanted. They chose for screen share and Godbolt. But anyways, so just if you're thinking these questions suck, we shouldn't ask them anymore. We're going to talk about that in a future episode. And my team doesn't.
因为我喜欢有编译器告诉我哪里做错了。但这就取决于候选人想要什么了。他们选择了屏幕共享和Godbolt。但无论如何，如果你觉得这些问题很烂，我们不应该再问了，我们将在未来的剧集里讨论这一点。而且我的团队不这样问。
I mean, if your team doesn't. Connor's a different team, does a different thing. I mean, admittedly, this is my first co-op interview or intern interview. And this is why I wasn't even sure if this was a good question anyways. So we're going to do this family feud style. Okay. I'm going to ask the question and we're going to put the top five answers on the board. And the five answers are five different algorithms that you can solve this problem with.
我的意思是，如果你的团队不这样问。康纳是另一个团队，做的事也不一样。好吧，诚实地说，这是我的第一次合作面试或实习生面试。这也是为什么我甚至不确定这到底是不是一个好问题。所以我们要以“家庭问答”的方式来做。好的。我要问这个问题，然后我们要把前五个答案写在黑板上。这五个答案是你可以用来解决这个问题的五种不同的算法。
And we're going to put what I think is the best at the bottom because it's probably if you're going the family feud style, the least people are going to think of it. Come at me if you think that the order of these is wrong, but I'm going to consider like sort of the number one answer on the board is the most naive sort of easiest way to do it algorithm. And then as you go down to number five, it'll be sort of the best way in my opinion. So try and guess number one first and then go from there to the bottom, but we'll see what happens. So here is the question. Given, and there's no corner cases, don't think the list is empty, blah, blah, blah. We're just going for the algorithms here. And then we'll talk about the fifth one if we get to it, which we will, because if Bryce doesn't get it, I'll just tell you. The question is, given a list of unique numbers, or it actually doesn't even need to be unique, there can be duplicates, return the top two in whatever form you want whatever pair array
我们要把我认为最好的放在最下面，因为如果你用“家庭问答”的风格，这可能是最少人会想到的。如果你觉得这些顺序不对，尽管来反驳我，但我会认为黑板上的头号答案是最朴素、最容易实现的算法。然后当你往下看到第五个时，依我之见，它基本上是最好的方法。所以先试着猜出第一个答案，然后从那里一直猜到最后一个，但我们来看看会发生什么。所以问题是这样的。给定一个列表，没有边界情况，别去想列表是不是空的之类的话。我们只关注算法。然后如果我们能聊到第五个的话，我们会聊第五个，实际上我们会的，因为如果布莱斯猜不出来，我会直接告诉你。问题是：给定一个唯一数字的列表，或者甚至不需要是唯一的，可以有重复，返回前两个数字，无论你用什么形式，不管是什么对数组
of length two vector of length two and don't worry about corner cases and stuff like that like i said so there's five there's five different algorithms that at least off of the top of my head i could think okay well let's let's go with sort ding ding ding ding ding that's answer top answer on the board i think i'm speaking too loud because i'm getting a little bit clippy on my end the number one answer is sort we've got zero strikes and uh that's your one algorithm down four to go let's see um and like we could talk about you know what to do with each of the algorithms but i'm'm going to assume that the top three, or maybe even four, you can figure out
长度为二的vector，并且不用担心边界情况之类的，就像我说的。所以至少在我脑海里，有五个——有五种不同的算法。好吧，让我们——让我们选“排序”。叮叮叮叮叮，那是黑板上的头号答案。我想我说话声音太大了，因为我这边的声音有点爆音。头号答案是“排序”。我们有零次失误，呃，你的第一个算法完成了，还有四个。让我们看看，呃……而且我们可以讨论一下，你知道，每种算法该怎么做，但我假设前三个，甚至可能是四个，你可以自己想出
the rest, because I really want to talk about the fifth one. Bryce guessed nth element. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding! That is the third answer on the board. I mean, obviously there's a reduction that you can do with this.
剩下的，因为我真的很想聊聊第五个。布莱斯猜了“nth_element”（第n个元素）。叮叮叮叮叮！那是黑板上的第三个答案。我的意思是，显然你可以用这个做一个归约（reduction）。
Is that an algorithm? Yeah. There's an algorithm called std reduce. Ding, ding, ding, ding, ding. I mean, technically— So, okay, let me explain why I go there in my mind. Because a parallel, you know, max element or min element is implemented through reduction. So me being someone who thinks in parallel by default, of course, my mind jumps first to that. And, you know, it's pretty easy to write a, well, okay, it's pretty straightforward to write
那是一个算法吗？是的。有一个算法叫std::reduce。叮叮叮叮叮。我的意思是，从技术上讲——所以，好吧，让我解释一下为什么它会出现在我的脑海里。因为并行的，你知道，max_element（最大元素）或min_element（最小元素）是通过归约实现的。所以作为一个默认进行并行思考的人，我的大脑自然首先会跳到那个。并且，你知道，编写一个，好吧，编写一个
a reduction operation that will give you, you know, the maximum in the input sequence. But it's also like, it's a pretty simple straight extension of that to just make it give you the two maximum, the two largest. In parallel? Yeah. Well, okay. Well, I mean, technically std reduce is not on the board. Well, you're, you're, I'm sorry, but you're wrong about that. But let's, let's assume there is a parallel algorithm on the board, but it's not std reduce.
归约操作来给你，你知道，输入序列中的最大值，其实相当简单，或者说相当直接。但它也一样，是一个相当简单直接的扩展，只需让它给你两个最大值，最大的两个。并行的？是的。好吧，好吧。我的意思是，从技术上讲std::reduce不在黑板上。好吧，你，你，我很抱歉，但你在这点上是错的。不过让我们，让我们假设黑板上有一个并行算法，但它不是std::reduce。
But you're telling me you can do it with std reduce and with like a parallel X. Why do you think that this can't be done with std reduce? Let's come back to it. Can you implement X element with std reduce? Yes. Then why could you not implement this with std reduce? What is the return type? What is the return type of your, that you're... A tuple of whatever your ints.
但你告诉我你可以用std::reduce和一个并行的X来做到这一点。为什么你认为这不能用std::reduce来完成？我们待会儿再回来讨论。你能用std::reduce实现nth_element吗？可以。那为什么你不能用std::reduce来实现这个？返回类型是什么？你的……的返回类型是什么？
This is integers, right? Perfect. Perfect. So like, how does that work? What is the initial argument to the accumulator that you're passing into std reduce if you're returning a tuple? A two element tuple um the the initial it's going to be like you know the minimum min value so right like the the numeric limits angle whatever your type is colon colon min but so you're initializing both of the two elements in your tuple to be the minimum and then how do you how do you implement your lambda so
这是整数，对吧？完美。完美。所以，这怎么运作呢？如果你返回一个元组，你传给std::reduce的累加器的初始参数是什么？一个双元素元组。呃，初始值将是，你知道的，最小值min value，所以，对吧，就像numeric_limits（数值极限）中不管你的类型是什么，然后是::min。所以你把元组中的两个元素都初始化为最小值，然后你如何，如何实现你的lambda，
that it works because you're the type of your list is just an integer and you now need to be able to go from an integer to a tuple um yeah so for for each integer you're gonna see um uh you know is this you're gonna do the max of that in the first element of the tuple and you store it, you store that to the first element of the tuple. What's the signature of the lambda? The lambda is going to take, you know, tuple of int, int. And so what's the problem with that now? Technically it also needs to take int tuple of int int and also tuple of int int and tuple of int int.
让它工作，因为你的列表类型只是一个整数，而你现在需要能够从一个整数转换到一个元组？是的，所以对于每个整数，你将看到，呃，你知道的，这是——你将对该整数和元组的第一个元素求最大值，然后你把它存储起来，存储到元组的第一个元素中。lambda的签名是什么？这个lambda将接受，你知道的，tuple。那么现在的问题在哪里？从技术上讲，它还需要接受int、tuple，还有tuple和tuple。
Okay, okay. So what Bryce has just... We've done like three episodes on this. I don't feel that I need to... So we will now put a sixth answer on the board and std reduce then is... Well, actually, we'll have a discussion, but I'll put it at number five on the board is std reduce then is, well, actually, we'll have a discussion, but I'll put it at number five on the board is std reduce.
好吧，好吧。所以布莱斯刚刚……我们已经做过大约三集关于这个的节目了。我觉得我不需要……所以我们现在要在黑板上加上第六个答案，然后std::reduce是……好吧，实际上，我们要讨论一下，但我会把它放在黑板上的第五个位置，std::reduce是，好吧，实际上，我们会讨论一下，但我会把它放在黑板上的第五个位置，std::reduce。
I'm certain that it's going to be the fastest way to solve this. We'll see, actually. I'm curious because you'll probably have a better idea than I will. But so the key here is that what Bryce has just explained is that it's not going to be a lambda. It's going to be a function object with overloads for a tuple of two ints and an int, two tuples, vice versa. But I think we've discussed in the past that there's a missing reduction that we should add and that if we had that, we would not need to have all of this combination of overloads. But you said std reduce though. So if you said
我确信这将是解决这个问题的最快方法。实际上，我们拭目以待。我很好奇，因为你的想法可能比我更好。但这里的关键是，布莱斯刚刚解释说，它不会是一个lambda。它将是一个函数对象，为“两个int的元组和一个int”、“两个元组”等提供重载，反之亦然。但我认为我们过去讨论过，有一个缺失的归约操作我们应该添加，如果我们有那个，我们就不需要所有这些重载的组合了。但你刚才说的是std::reduce。所以如果你说的是
associative reduce, then that would have been okay. have been okay fine the associative reduce fine all right so that is definitely so but then associative reduce is definitely not faster than the number six answer on the board so to recap number one is sort number three uh no actually yeah you might be right you might be right but i i know that the i know that the sixth algorithm doesn't need to be associative so it is like the purest of the parallel algorithms but to recap number one sort number three nth element number five stood reduce or associative reduce can you guess number two and four before we go to six and number two and four to give you a hint are not parallel i mean i guess you could have parallel versions,
结合性归约（associative reduce），那就可以了。那就可以了，很好，结合性归约，很好。好的，所以那绝对是——但结合性归约绝对没有黑板上的第六个答案快。所以总结一下，第一名是排序，第三名，呃，不，其实，是的，你可能是对的，你可能是对的，但我知道，我知道第六个算法不需要是结合性的，所以它是最纯粹的并行算法。但总结一下，第一名排序，第三名nth_element，第五名std::reduce或结合性归约。在你我们转到第六个之前，你能猜出第二名和第四名吗？给你个提示，第二名和第四名不是并行的。我的意思是，我想你可以有并行版本，
but they're in just the regular C++11 algorithm header. Can you think of the one that sits between sort and nth element? The one that sits between? Well, I mean, partition? Is partition on there? Partition won't work because partition takes a unary predicate so you can't really construct a unary predicate that'll return you the top two unless if you go ahead and do a reduction in the first place but then that sort of defeats the purpose it's a it's a type of sort
但它们只在常规的C++11算法头文件中。你能想到排在排序和nth_element之间的那个吗？排在中间的那个？嗯，我的意思是，partition（分区）？partition在上面吗？partition不会起作用，因为partition接受一个一元谓词（unary predicate），所以你真的无法构造一个一元谓词来返回前两个，除非你一开始就做一个归约，但那某种程度上就失去了意义。它是一种排序
uh well there's there's partial sort right ding ding ding ding ding so like he said sorting and i didn't realize that you were like asking for um all the specific algorithm calls i assumed that when i like sort and i assumed that i had that covered whatever all right partial sort number two on the board and i'll give you number four because you basically already said it it's stood accumulate which is just the sequential serial version yeah all right so can you think on but there's um uh there's like there's other algorithms here that you could do um is there well so you know it's interesting that you say do. Is there? Well, so, you know, it's interesting that you said like, okay, so we already have an
呃，这里有partial_sort（局部排序），对吧？叮叮叮叮叮！所以就像他说的排序，我没有意识到你是在要求所有具体的算法调用。我以为当我像排序那样做时，我已经涵盖了它，管他呢。好吧，partial_sort是黑板上的第二名。我把第四名告诉你，因为你基本上已经说过了，它是std::accumulate，这只是顺序的串行版本。好的，所以你能想到，但是这里还有其他的算法你可以做。有吗？所以，你知道，你这么说很有趣。有吗？所以，你知道，你刚才说，好吧，所以我们已经有了一个
algorithm that's very similar to this. I know. Which is the max element. Well, so actually, I skipped this, but that was the first question that I asked in this interview. My first question, and actually, so this question is the... So is it a list of, like, is it positive integers? It can be any type of integers. If it's whatever the integer is, unsigned, signed, it works well.
与这个非常相似的算法。我知道。也就是max_element。好吧，其实我跳过了这个，但这是我在这次面试中问的第一个问题。我的第一个问题，实际上，所以这个问题是……所以这是一个列表，比如，它是正整数吗？它可以是任何类型的整数。不管是什么整数，无符号的、有符号的，它都运作良好。
But this is very similar, like, the algorithm that you're asking for is very similar to min-max element. And that min-max element is a single pass version that tracks two different extremas. That is true. But the implementation of min-max element, like the details in there are non-trivial. So like bending a reduction to work like that, it's not like a trivial thing. What do you mean they're non-trivial? What do you mean they're non-trivial? What do you mean they're not trivial? And wait, so like, let's just pause though, because our listeners, our listener could be a bit confused because I said that it's actually the first
但这非常相似，就像你问的算法与min_max_element非常相似。而min_max_element是一个单遍版本（single pass version），它跟踪两个不同的极值。确实如此。但min_max_element的实现，就像那里的细节是非微不足道的（non-trivial）。所以扭曲一个归约来那样工作，它不是一件微不足道的事情。你是什么意思它们不是微不足道的？你是什么意思它们不是微不足道的？你是什么意思它们不是微不足道的？等一下，我们就此暂停一下，因为我们的听众，我们的听众可能会有点困惑，因为我说这其实是我问的第一个
question I asked. So we did the 20 minutes of talking about, you know, resume, random stuff, passion for C++. Then my actual question was return from a list of numbers, the smallest and largest. And in my head, I had a backup question because if the candidate said min max element, like that's a hundred percent, we don't even need to, like, if you know the algorithm, you're done the question, which is to answer some people's who asked this question on LeetCode or Reddit, you know, do interviewers care about knowing the algorithms or they're going to ask you to implement it? It's no, like, I'm not going to ask you to implement an algorithm that already exists. Because if you're on the day job, like you're not going to have to program min max element, like, it's a good exercise to
问题。所以我们花了20分钟讨论简历、随机的事情、对C++的热情。然后我的实际问题是：从一个数字列表中返回最小和最大值。在我的脑海里，我有一个备用问题，因为如果候选人说出min_max_element，那就百分之百搞定，我们甚至不需要，如果你知道这个算法，你就完成了这个问题。这也是为了回答一些在LeetCode或Reddit上问这个问题的人：面试官在乎知道这些算法吗，还是会要求你实现它？答案是不，我不回要求你实现一个已经存在的算法。因为如果在日常工作中，你不需要编写min_max_element，虽然这是一个很好的练习
know how to do it. But I would rather have you implement an algorithm that you might actually end up having to write on the day job, not one that you know, you won't have to write. So that being said, the second question I asked him is the one that we are talking about right now. And so, yeah, like going from std reduce to min max is non-trivial in my opinion. And we've talked about the top five. And so for a std reduce, in order to do it in parallel, you have to define a function object with a bunch of overloads, which I think is like that's non-trivial.
去了解它是如何运作的。但我宁愿让你实现一个你可能最终在日常工作中不得不编写的算法，而不是一个你知道你不需要编写的算法。话虽如此，我问他的第二个问题就是我们现在正在谈论的这个。所以，是的，在我看来，从std::reduce到min_max并不是微不足道的。我们已经讨论了前五名。对于std::reduce，为了并行完成它，你必须定义一个带有许多重载的函数对象，我认为这就像——那不是微不足道的。
And you'd have to do the same thing for min-max element. But there is an algorithm that you can, a parallel algorithm that you can use where I actually don't know if it would be more efficient than the std reduce with the overloads. My guess is that it would be a tiny bit slower, but I don't know. I'd have to profile it.
你对min_max_element也必须做同样的事情。但有一个算法你可以用，一个你可以使用的并行算法，我实际上不知道它是否会比带有重载的std::reduce更高效。我的猜测是它会稍微慢一点，但我不知道。我必须对它进行性能剖析（profile）。
I actually have no idea. And we're going to talk about that. I'm desperately Googling because I do not buy your claims about the complexity of implementing MinMax element. It's pretty straightforward. I mean, in Thrust, we just do it with tuples. It's pretty straightforward, I gotta say. I mean, but that's the thing is min-max element is a lot simpler than top two.
我实际上完全不知道。我们要讨论那个。我正在拼命Google，因为我不买账你关于实现MinMax element复杂度的说辞。这相当简单。我的意思是，在Thrust中，我们只用元组来做。说实话，这相当简单。我的意思是，但关键是min_max_element比top two要简单得多。
Like when you do min-max, you're literally just doing two reductions at the same time that are orthogonal from each other. Whereas top two, they're not orthogonal. You have like six different cases that you need to check is the current element greater than your your biggest element if yes then like shift your first one to the second one replace it with the first one if it's not then you gotta check is it greater than the second one if so replace it and when you're doing it in parallel it's a lot more
就像当你做最小最大值（min-max）时，你实际上只是在同时做两个相互正交的归约。然而在前两名（top two）中，它们是不正交的。你需要检查大约六种不同的情况：当前元素是否大于你最大的元素？如果是，把第一个元素移到第二个，用当前元素替换第一个；如果不是，你得检查它是否大于第二个元素，如果是的话就替换它。当并行处理时，这要复杂得多...
complicated um i don't i don't think it's a lot more complicated i think that one can write this pretty pretty neatly what's the neat way is this to reduce i i'm not gonna try to do it live now but between but after we're done here maybe i will i agree that it's like not like you know one or two lines of code but i still think it's not like one or two lines of code, but I still think it's pretty clean. I don't think this is tricky. Is it with a std reduce, though? Yeah, with a std reduce. Okay, with a std associative reduce. So I agree.
复杂，嗯，我不——我不觉得复杂得多，我觉得完全可以写得相当整洁。什么是整洁的方法？是做归约吗？我——我不打算现在现场写，但等我们录完之后也许我会。我同意这不像是那一两行代码，但我还是觉得它不算是那一两行代码，不过我依然觉得它相当干净。我不认为这很棘手。不过这是用 std::reduce 吗？对，用 std::reduce。好吧，用 std::associative::reduce。所以我同意。
Associative reduce, it's easy because you don't need to worry about commutativity, and you can just have the tuple. You can have your accumulator as a pair or a two tuple and your second element as an integer but with std reduce it's like with an existing i mean there is another algorithm that you can do it without creating a function object with a bunch of overloads but with std reduce i don't think it's trivial and the algorithm that i think makes it a lot easier, but I'm not sure if it's faster than the std reduce with the function object with overloads is transform reduce, where you transform each of your integers to a two tuple or a pair where the first element...
关联归约（associative reduce）很简单，因为你不需要担心可交换性（commutativity），你可以直接用元组（tuple）。你可以把累加器（accumulator）设为一个 pair 或双元素元组（two tuple），第二个元素设为一个整数。但用 std::reduce 的话，就像现有的——我的意思是，还有另一种算法，你不需要创建一个带有一堆重载的函数对象（function object）就能做到这一点。但用 std::reduce，我觉得它并不是显而易见的。而且我认为让它变得容易得多的算法——不过我不确定它是否比带重载的函数对象的 std::reduce 更快——是变换归约（transform reduce），在这里你把每个整数变换成一个双元素元组或 pair，其中第一个元素...
This is nonsense. This is nonsense. That's just like, what you're just describing is the way that you would implement this with reduce i said i want to do this with reduce and you said you want to do this with transform reduce well me doing it with reduce like those are two equivalent things like i'll just do it with reduce and just use like a like mine doesn't work mine does not require defining a function object with like the function call operator overloaded four different times. Neither does mine. Whatever your solution is, it boils down to some form of my solution where I just use views transform. Like transform reduce is to some degree now almost redundant in light of the existence of ranges.
这简直是无稽之谈。这纯属胡扯。这就好比——你刚才描述的正是你用 reduce 实现它的方式。我说我想用 reduce 来做，而你说你想用 transform reduce 来做。好吧，我用 reduce 做和那个——那是两码事，我会直接用 reduce，然后用类似——我的代码怎么了？我的代码不需要定义一个把函数调用运算符重载了四次的函数对象。我的也不需要。不管你的解决方案是什么，归根结底都某种程度上变成了我的方案——我只是用了 views::transform。从某种程度上说，鉴于 ranges 的存在，transform reduce 现在几乎是多余的。
I mean, we still probably need it as a customization point. Using std reduce with a views transform is the same as transform reduce. Right, right. I think we're in agreement. You didn't say that, though. You said that you needed operator overloadinging which is non-trivial yeah i think if i was writing it down i would have come to the conclusion that the easiest way to do that would have been with the reduction don't give me a hard time here well with with the with the
我的意思是，我们可能仍然需要它作为定制点（customization point）。使用带 views::transform 的 std::reduce 和 transform reduce 是一样的。对，对。我想我们达成了共识。不过你刚才没这么说。你说你需要运算符重载，这可不简单。好吧，我想如果我把它写下来，我会得出结论：最简单的方法还是用归约。别为难我了。好吧，带有带有...
transform but but but like like like to me i would just like writing that that operator like in having it like that that is as straightforward to me as writing um as as having a transform operator in there really i'll i'll i'll admit that your way probably is you know probably fewer lines of code but i'm not i'm not totally sold convinced by that i mean i think the difference between a function object with four overloads and uh two lambdas in a transform reduce or a views transform with a stood reduce i think i think the latter is way more ergonomic to write i think i think we i think you and i were saying the same thing Yeah, like the, so the way that Thrust implements it is with a call to reduce with a special function object that takes, that operates on, you know, tuples and with a transform iterator that converts the input sequence into these, you know, tuples
变换，但但但——对我来说，我宁愿写那个运算符——让它像那样，对我来说，这和写一个变换运算符一样直截了当。真的，我——我——我承认你的方式可能（你知道的）代码行数更少，但我并不——并不完全被它说服。我的意思是，我认为带四个重载的函数对象与带两个 lambda 表达式的 transform reduce（或带 std::reduce 的 views::transform）之间的区别，后者写起来要符合人体工程学得多。我觉得——我觉得我们——你和我其实说的是同一件事。对，比如，Thrust 的实现方式是通过调用 reduce，配合一个特殊的函数对象，该函数对象对（你知道的）元组进行操作，并配合一个变换迭代器（transform iterator），将输入序列转换为这些（你知道的）元组
so that the reduction operator doesn't have to handle all these cases, which I think is exactly what you just said. Well, I mean, that's a third different way of doing it, which is the same idea. They will lead to the same generated code. I'm not a compiler, so I don't even know if that's true. I am a compiler. I will tell you that these lead to the same code.
这样归约运算符就不必处理所有这些情况了，我觉得这完全就是你刚才说的。我的意思是，那是第三种实现方法，但原理是一样的。它们会生成相同的代码。我不是编译器，所以我甚至不知道这是不是真的。我是编译器。我可以告诉你，这些代码生成的代码是完全一样的。
One's a transform reduce. One's a reduce with a transform, a view transform. And the other one's a std reduce with a transform iterator. I am other ones a stood reduce with a transform iterator i am uninterested in like the specific details of how you write the reduction um the there's you know all forms of writing the reduction to solve this problem are going to be more or less equivalent and importantly have more or less the same performance profile both in serial and in parallel especially in comparison to all the other solutions that we just discussed i mean i'm not a experienced enough gpu programmer to know that that's true there's so
一个是 transform reduce。一个是带 view transform 的 reduce。另一个是带变换迭代器的 std::reduce。另一个是带变换迭代器的 std::reduce，我对你编写归约的具体细节不感兴趣，嗯——你知道的，编写归约来解决这个问题的各种形式大同小异，重要的是它们具有差不多相同的性能表现，无论是在串行还是并行情况下，特别是与我们刚才讨论的所有其他解决方案相比。我的意思是，我不是经验丰富的 GPU 程序员，不知道这是不是真的，这里有
there are the sorting based approaches that we talked about which are obviously you know going to be not great performance wise for solving this um in in the in the common case um i'm sure there's going to be some some cases like maybe small input size where that is just the fastest thing to do or something. But let's just assume that all of the sorting based things like the int element, the partial sort, and the sort, like all of those are going to be slow. And then there is the approach that is to do two reductions, to like sort of do this in two passes. There are answers of that category, which are probably a little bit cruder, but work. And then there's all of the like,
我们讨论过的基于排序的方法，很显然（你知道的）在常见情况下，用它们来解决这个问题的性能不会太好。我确信会有某些情况——比如较小的输入规模，排序可能是最快的方法之类。但我们假设所有基于排序的方法，比如 nth_element、partial_sort 和 sort，所有这些都会很慢。然后还有一种方法是做两次归约，也就是分两趟（two passes）来做。属于这一类的答案可能有点粗糙，但确实管用。然后还有所有那些...
all of the answers that do this in a single reduction pass. And like, that's how I break down like the answers that you can give to this question and also like the quality of said answers. Because like the answer that will give you the best performance will be like the quality of said answers because like the answer that will give you the best performance will be like the answers that give you the single pass reduction yeah i guess it's from like my inexperienced point of view i don't know that lifting your elements into a tuple in a transform iterator pass or in the transform reduce version or in the views transform version
所有在单趟归约中完成的答案。这就是我对你可以给出的答案以及这些答案质量的分类方式。因为能给你带来最佳性能的答案会是——这些答案的质量，因为能给你带来最佳性能的答案会是——那些单趟归约的答案。好吧，我想从我这个缺乏经验的角度来看，我不知道在变换迭代器遍历中、在 transform reduce 版本中、或者在 views::transform 版本中把元素提升为元组
plus a reduce i don't know if that's like i think that there's a possibility that's slower than the first version that you said the stood reduce with a function object with four i don't i i'm i'm very confident that um because you have to understand like how the transform view like works under the hood, where it's quite similar to Enthrust, like a transform iterator. And so because of that, under the hood, it's the moral equivalent as if you had a really fancy reduction operator that had all these overloads. Because you're not, keep in mind, in a transform reduce, you're not actually doing a transform pass beforehand. You're doing it on the fly. Like every time you evaluate the reduction
再加上一个 reduce，我不知道这是否——我觉得这有可能比你说的第一个版本（带有四个重载的函数对象的 std::reduce）还要慢。我不——我非常确信，因为你必须理解变换视图（transform view）在底层是如何工作的，它非常类似于 Thrust 中的变换迭代器。正因如此，在底层，它的效果在本质上等同于你拥有一个真正华丽的、拥有所有这些重载的归约运算符。因为记住，在 transform reduce 中，你实际上并没有预先进行一次变换遍历。你是动态（on the fly）进行的。就像每次你评估归约
operation, that's when you're doing the transform. It's only a pseudo sequence that gets produced. You're not actually producing it and storing it somewhere. And so because of that, you know, it's, you know, you can think of that transform as being done as part of that reduction operation. I guess that's the thing is I've never done any real profiling of algorithms, but like, or see if my thoughts on this if they're consistent with yours though that i agree that like the three different spellings of the transform reduce one where it boils down to some kind of iterator thing are all similar but the one with the function object with the overloads my thoughts is like you're gonna have 80 less construction uh or not 80% less, you will have 80% the amount.
操作时，你就是在做变换。这只是产生了一个伪序列（pseudo sequence）。你并没有真正生成它并把它存储在某个地方。正因如此，你知道的，你可以认为那个变换是作为归约操作的一部分来完成的。我想问题在于，我从未对算法做过任何真正的性能剖析（profiling），但我对这一点的看法是否与你的一致：我同意 transform reduce 的三种不同写法（归根结底都某种程度上涉及迭代器之类的东西）其实都差不多，但带有重载的函数对象的那个版本，我的想法是：你的构造开销会减少 80%...
So like 20% less of the construction of two tuples or pairs because of the fact that some of the times when you're merging, you know, the two top things together, it's going to be coming from an int that hasn't been transformed into a two tuple and just goes directly into the two tuple that is being merged with is that does that not affect perf the compiler is going to optimize all that away really yes really yes like like if you if you if if you construct a tuple of like two ints from one source int and then you only ever really use one of those two elements of the tuple somewhere. The tuple does not exist by the time it gets to the compiler middle end or back end. The compiler is just going to optimize all this away.
或者不是少 80%，你会保留 80% 的量。所以构造两个元素的元组或 pair 的开销会减少 20% 左右。因为事实上，有时当你把两个顶部的对象合并在一起时，它来自一个尚未被变换为双元素元组的 int，而是直接进入了正在与之合并的双元组中。这难道不会影响性能吗？编译器会把所有这些都优化掉的。真的吗？真的。就像——如果你——如果你从一个源 int 构造了一个包含两个 int 的元组，然后你实际上只在某处用到了该元组的这两个元素中的一个。当它到达编译器的中端（middle end）或后端时，这个元组根本就不存在了。编译器会把所有这些完全优化掉的。
Really? Yeah. Another data point for you that will be useful. How do you think thrust transform reduce is implemented? We just already said that. You told me that earlier on the show. Transform iterator and a reduce. Right. So, like, we asked for this customization point of transform reduce,
真的吗？对。再给你提供一个有用数据点。你认为 thrust::transform reduce 是怎么实现的？我们刚才已经说过了。你节目早些时候告诉过我了。变换迭代器和一个 reduce。对，所以，我们要求提供 transform reduce 这个定制点，
but we only really needed it because we didn't yet have views transform. We don't do anything special for that case. We literally just use a transform iterator because that's an abstraction that will just be completely optimized away so i i definitely understand that part the part that i just i i believe you because you definitely know more about this but it's it is just surprising to me that like in in the version that boils down
但我们真正需要它，只是因为当时我们还没有 views::transform。针对这种情况我们并没有做什么特殊处理。我们实际上只是用了变换迭代器，因为那是一种会被完全优化掉的抽象。所以我绝对理解那一部分。我之所以——我相信你，因为你对这方面的了解肯定比我多，但让我惊讶的是，在归根结底
to a transform iterator plus a std reduce you are always calling a binary operation that takes two pairs of two tuples. Whereas in the version with the function overload, you are not always dealing. You've got four different times. The majority of the time, and definitely basically once every element's been hit once, you're always going to be going to the two-tuple version. Actually, that might not even be... What I'm getting at is that I'm fairly confident that with most optimizing compilers, with optimizations turned on, writing those two forms of the code will give you equivalent code gen. Really?
是变换迭代器加上 std::reduce 的版本中，你调用的始终是一个接受两个双元素元组对的二元操作。而在带有函数重载的版本中，你并不总是处理这些。你有四种不同的情况。绝大多数时候，基本上只要每个元素都被访问过一次，你最终总是会进入双元组版本。实际上，这甚至可能不是……我的意思是，我相当确信，对于大多数开启了优化的优化编译器来说，编写这两种形式的代码会产生等效的代码生成（code gen）。真的吗？
Yeah. Now I'm super curious. Compilers are pretty amazing. I agree, but like. Let me put it to you this way. In those two different ways of writing the code, you are doing the same thing and you're taking the same path to get to the result. And I do not believe that there is any observable difference between those two ways of writing the code. If we were talking about non-intruder types, like a, like a type that had like, you know,
对。现在我超级好奇。编译器真是太神奇了。我同意，但——我这么跟你说吧。在这两种不同的代码编写方式中，你做的是同一件事，并且你走的是同一条路径来得到结果。我不相信这两种代码编写方式之间会有任何可观测到的差异。如果我们讨论的是非平凡类型（non-trivial types），比如一个在其构造函数中带有...
stood C out in its constructor, sure, these two ways of writing the code would be meaningfully different. But in this case, we're talking about, you know, reductions on ints and tuples of ints. And so like these two different ways of writing the code will not be meaningfully different and like will be optimized to the same to the same output code now i want to talk about one other way of solving this problem that i think might be some people's first intuition. And that way is to do something like max element, then take it out, and then max element again. Now, this is problematic in a few ways.
std::cout 的类型，当然，这两种编写代码的方式会有显著的不同。但在这个例子中，我们讨论的是对 int 以及 int 的元组的归约。因此，这两种不同的代码编写方式不会有显著的不同，并且会被优化为相同的输出代码。现在我想谈谈解决这个问题的另一种方法，我认为这可能是某些人的第一直觉。这种方法就是做类似 max_element，把它拿出来，然后再做一次 max_element。这在几个方面是有问题的。
Because one, you could have had multiple... What did you do if you had two values um that had the same maximum value like what if the the highest the there were you know the highest value in the the list was five um but there were two fives well then it's not sufficient to just get rid like just remove at the iterator returned by max element um wait is it not that still work no because then you when you run max element the second time you're going to find the other five and you wanted to find you wanted to get rid of maximum it was no it was um you see well that's why it was interesting that that you started off by saying unique numbers and then you said it doesn't matter whether they're unique or not i actually posit that it does. Because if they are unique numbers, then the max element, remove whatever that iterator was, max element again is a valid solution.
因为第一，你可能会有多个……如果你有两个值，它们的具有相同的最大值，会怎么样？比如，如果列表中最高的值是 5，但有两个 5，那么仅仅摆脱——移除由 max_element 返回的迭代器是不够的——等等，这样难道不行吗？不行，因为当你第二次运行 max_element 时，你会找到另一个 5，而你想找的是——你想摆脱最大值，它不是——它是——你看，这就是为什么一开始你说“唯一的数字”（unique numbers），然后又说数字唯一与否并不重要，这很有意思。我其实认为这很重要。因为如果它们是唯一的数字，那么 max_element，移除那个迭代器，再来一次 max_element 就是一个有效的解决方案。
Not the fastest one, but one of the reasons why I think it's one that people will jump to is that it's a solution that does not involve... The first thing that'll pop into people's minds is sort, which is obviously going to be quite slow. And then they're like, well, maybe there's a quicker way and then they'll be happy to find something that's not sort levels of complexity. So like, oh yeah, we can just do two two max element passes i think it's like a step further to to recognize that you can solve this in the single pass well so uh the reason i said duplicates don't matter is because in my head returning the same value would have been fine if there's if there's duplicates you can return five five oh that's interesting um that was a different problem i did not read that as being acceptable
虽然不是最快的，但我认为人们会直接跳到这个方案的原因之一是，它是一个不涉及——人们脑海中首先浮现的会是排序（sort），这显然会相当慢。然后他们会想，好吧，也许有更快的方法，于是他们会很高兴找到一个复杂度没有达到排序级别的方案。所以，哦，对，我们只需进行两次 max_element 遍历。我觉得认识到可以通过单趟遍历解决这个问题，又进了一步。好吧，所以——我之前说重复项不重要，是因为在我看来，如果有重复项的话，返回相同的值也是可以接受的。你可以返回 5, 5。哦，那很有意思。那是个不同的问题，我没看出那是可以接受的。
because you you said uh you see you said given a list of numbers return the top two and i think that's an ill-formed question what like the top two what the top two like the okay it's not specific enough the top two values yeah yeah it definitely doesn't exclude the possibility of what i meant it to be to be the case um but it's not specific enough yes i agree i and i i think that there's probably another class of solution here um where you do something clever with min max element um maybe it's a two pass one too but this this popped into my mind as well min max element doesn't take an overload though so yeah but you do so you do something with transform
因为你说过——你看，你说过“给定一个列表的数字，返回前两名（top two）”，我觉得这是一个定义不清的问题。什么叫——前两名是什么？前两名——好吧，它不够具体。前两名价值，对，对，它绝对没有排除我原本想表达的意思的可能性，但它确实不够具体。是的，我同意。而且我认为这里可能还有另一类解决方案，你用 min_max_element 做一些聪明的操作，也许这也是个两趟遍历的方案？但这也在我脑海中闪过。不过 min_max_element 不接受重载，所以——对，但你可以通过变换来做...
uh uh you know with transform views views. You think? Let me put it to you this way. Okay, this is obviously not practical, but this is just the thing that jumped to my mind. What jumped to my mind is like, well, MinMax... So we've gone from practical solutions to perverse solutions now. How are you bending min-max? What we're looking for here is a reduction that finds two different things based upon their value relative to the other elements.
——你知道的，用 transform views。你觉得呢？我这么跟你说吧。好吧，这显然不切实际，但这正是我脑海中闪过的东西。我脑海中浮现的是，好吧，min_max——所以我们现在已经从切实可行的解决方案走向了离经叛道的解决方案。你是怎么魔改 min_max 的？我们这里寻找的是一种归约，它根据元素相对于其他元素的值来找出两个不同的东西。
And we already have one of those min-max elements. And like, we already have one of those min-max element. And so if there was just some way of making the, like, that's why I asked if all the numbers were positive. If all the numbers were positive and there was just some way of inverting all of the top two values to be negative, then you could just do it with min-max of course to know but that would that would require you to know what the uh uh what the top two what the second of the of the top two is and once if you've already known that then you might as well just do another max element does that make sense yeah which is why which is why min max element does not there's no there's no useful way to use it here.
我们已经有了其中一个 min_max_element。而且——我们已经有了其中一个 min_max_element。所以如果有什么方法能让——这就是我为什么问所有数字是否都是正数。如果所有的数字都是正数，并且有什么办法把前两个值全部反转为负数，那么你当然可以用 min_max 来做，但那需要你知道前两个值——也就是前两个值中的第二个是什么。一旦你已经知道了那个，你还不如直接再做一次 max_element。这说得通吗？对。这就是为什么——这就是为什么 min_max_element 在这里没有用武之地。
Yeah, I see. Yeah, I see what you're thinking. Yeah, but that would require like an extra pass up front, which you just said doesn't make sense at that point. I wonder how many people actually are brave enough to say sort. said it first because i don't have to worry about you um uh about you judging me for saying the one that's going to be quite slow um but like if in an interview i bet somebody's not going to say sort because like that is the naive solution right because it's not particularly efficient when you ask this in an interview, do you do the family feud thing? I assume not. No, no, I did that for entertainment purposes, although I thought it would have been a curious way to go about it. If I was in an interview,
对，我明白。对，我明白你的想法。是的，但这需要在前面进行一次额外的遍历，你刚才已经说过，那样做就没有意义了。我想知道到底有多少人有勇气说出“sort”。我先说了，因为我不必担心你会因为我说了一个会相当慢的方案而评判我。但在面试中，我敢打赌有人不会说 sort，因为那是很天真的解决方案，对吧？因为当你在面试中问这个时，你会玩“家庭问答”（family feud）的游戏吗？我想不会。不，不，我那样做是为了娱乐目的，虽然我觉得这会是一种奇怪的做法。如果我在面试中，
I probably would have answered it with sort so that then I could get the interviewer to ask me, well could you do better than that yeah and uh well so so here's the real question is uh you know uh now that we've been edged or i've been educated because i think that's that's the thing is i went in thinking i have a transform reduce solution that i coded because i actually started with stood reduce wrote it up and then was like, oh, no, wait, like, I don't have a commutative lambda. And so I was like, oh, God, does that mean I need to go do the function object thing? And so then I was like, oh, if I lifted each of the elements into a pair, that'll work. But then that was my thought is like, I actually don't know if that is less efficient than the function object. So our resident parallel algorithm expert says it
我可能就会用 sort 来回答，这样我就可以让面试官追问我：“嗯，你能做得比这更好吗？”对。好吧，所以——真正的问法是，（你知道的）现在我们被启发了——或者说我被教育了，因为我觉得事情是这样的：我进去时以为我有一个自己编写的 transform reduce 解决方案，因为我实际上是从 std::reduce 开始写的，写完后发现：“哦，不，等等，我没有一个可交换的 lambda。”于是我想：“天哪，这是否意味着我得去搞那个函数对象的东西？”然后我想：“哦，如果我把每个元素都提升为一个 pair，那就行了。”但当时我的想法是：我其实不知道这是否比函数对象效率低。所以我们常驻的并行算法专家说...
basically boils down to the same thing. So now that we have our six answers on the board, plus also the two max elements as well, the question is, is that a good or bad question for an interview? Well, I'm going to posit that all of the interview questions that your team or my team have asked, or maybe not all, I'll say like 90% of the interview questions that have been asked by your team or my team, not by my team anymore because we're not doing those anymore but 90 of those questions have been questions that where the answer has either been stood reduce or stood atomic um like when i interviewed at nvidia i had
基本上归结为一回事。所以现在我们在板上有了六个答案，外加两个最大元素，问题是，这对面试来说是个好问题还是坏问题？嗯，我要断言，你的团队或我的团队问过的所有面试问题，或者也许不是全部，我可以说大概90%的面试问题，都是由你的团队或我的团队问过的——现在不再由我的团队问了，因为我们不再做那些了——但其中90%的问题，答案要么是std::reduce，要么是std::atomic，比如我在英伟达面试的时候，我经历过
eight interview rounds this is back in 2017 and um and all of the interview questions were answered with stood atomic and it was only after the first four rounds of interviews that i realized that it was all driver engineers who only understood c and who expected me to answer with like volatile loads in stores and didn't had no idea what I was talking about, but we're like, he seems to know what he's talking about. Um, so like if in the sense that like it falls into the regime of a question that is answered with std reduce, um, sure. It's a good question. Like the, the, the, I'll, I'll tell you why the questions that are answered with std reduce are good questions, because you can usually tell by how people construct the answer to the question whether they are thinking in parallel by default or not. Oh, yeah.
八轮面试，那是2017年的事，而且所有的面试问题都是用std::atomic回答的，直到前四轮面试之后我才意识到，原来全都是只懂C语言的驱动工程师，他们期望我用类似于volatile的加载和存储来回答，根本不知道我在说什么，但他们觉得：嗯，他好像知道自己在说什么。所以，如果从它属于一个用std::reduce回答的问题的意义上来说，当然，这是个好问题。比如，我、我、我来告诉你为什么用std::reduce回答的问题是好问题，因为你通常可以通过人们如何构建对这个问题的答案，来判断他们默认是否具有并行思维。哦，是的。
But that's the thing is like in my head, if I had gotten this question while I was interviewing, which was a couple years ago now, there's no way I would have answered the std reduce or std transform reduce. I never would have gotten to that point because at that point I did not understand the requirements on std. Would you have answered with accumulate? Yeah, I would have done it with a std accumulate. And then and then like so basically the associated reduce version. If somebody answers this question with accumulate, then you ask okay well how do you paralyze it well so and this is where like i'm curious is what level would you expect um an intern uh to be able to get up to because like i couldn't have gotten to and i don't think I was expecting, I think I would have been blown away if they had gotten to Stidridus.
但问题是，在我的脑海里，如果我在面试时遇到这个问题——那已经是几年前的事了——我绝不可能回答std::reduce或std::transform reduce。我永远不会走到那一步，因为当时我根本不理解对std的要求。你会用accumulate回答吗？对，我会用std::accumulate来做。然后，基本上就是关联归约版本。如果有人用accumulate回答这个问题，你就会问：好吧，那你怎么把它并行化呢？所以，这就是我好奇的地方，你期望实习生能够达到什么水平？因为我当时不可能做到，而且我不认为我当时有这个期望，如果他们能答出std::reduce，我会震惊得无以复加。
I don't expect interns or anybody who's interviewing to be able to, like, I do not think that the answers this question is not going to like convince me that they shouldn't work at the company it might so the answer is they should but there's no level uh you have no expectation basically um i just don't think this is a good way to evaluate people. I think it's a good way to, like, I think if you have somebody that's an intern or a new college graduate where they have no, there might be an effective way to determine that they're good. But if somebody flubs this question, or if somebody flubs any technical interview question, I do not think I would hold it against them. So it's, yeah, it's basically what I said.
我并不期望实习生或任何来面试的人能够……也就是说，我不认为这个问题的答案会让我觉得他们不应该在这家公司工作。也许会，答案应该是“他们应该被录用”，但并没有什么水平限制……基本上你没有任何预期。我只是觉得这不是评估人的好方法。我觉得这是一种好方法，如果你有一个实习生或应届毕业生，他们一无所有，这可能是一种确定他们很优秀的方法搞定。但如果有人在这个问题上砸了锅，或者在任何技术面试问题上砸了锅，我想我不会记恨他们。所以，是的，这基本上就是我刚才说的。
It's like a non-answer answer. A, B, C, that's basically what I said. It's like a non-answer. It's a non-answer answer. A, B, C, or D. Well, I don't think this question can really tell us anything. It might tell us something, but it won't tell us the absence of something. It's like, okay. I mean, I think it's a good, you know, like it's good in that like it lets you ask many follow-up questions. And like it lets you, yeah, like sure, if you're going to ask a technical question, I think it's good in that like it it lets you ask many follow-up questions and like it lets you yeah like sure if you're gonna ask a technical question i think it's good um but we just shouldn't ask
这就像一个非答案式的答案。A、B、C，这基本上就是我说的。就像一个非答案。这是一个非答案的答案。A、B或C。嗯，我觉得这个问题真的说明不了什么。它可能说明了一点什么，但它说明不了某种东西的缺失。好吧。我的意思是，我觉得这是一个好问题，你知道的，它好在能让你提出很多后续问题。就像它能让你……是的，如果你一定要问一个技术问题，我觉得它好在它能让你提出很多后续问题，并且能让你……是的，如果你要问一个技术问题，我觉得它挺好的，但我们就是不应该去问
those yeah we should focus on well we'll save that to a follow-up episode because yeah eric niebler had a tweet that kind of went i actually don't't know what level of virality is normal or not normal for him, but when I saw it, I think it had a triple or quadruple a triple or quadruple digit number of likes and a triple digit number of retweets.
那些问题。是的，我们应该专注于……嗯，我们会把这个留到后面的节目再聊，因为埃里克·尼布勒（Eric Niebler）发了一条推文，差不多……其实我也不知道对他来说什么样的病毒式传播水平算正常或不正常，但当我看到它的时候，我想它有三位数或四位数的点赞量，还有三位数的转发量。
For my level, where I'm at on Twitter, I was like, whoa, that popped off. But maybe that's just a day in the... I've gained like 600 Twitter followers in the past week or so. Yeah, I have not. Yeah, I have a good number more than Eric. I have, you know, my Twitter followers appreciate the APL content.
以我在推特上的水平来看，我想：哇，这条火了。但也许这只是……我过去一周左右在推特上增加了大约600个粉丝。是的，我没有。是的，我的粉丝数量比埃里克多不少。你知道，我的推特粉丝很欣赏APL的内容。
So, you know, that's what's important. I have 11.6K. I'm comfortably ahead of JF now. Like there's no world in which JF is going to catch up. He's got 10.2K. That's a dangerous thing to say. I am confident. I am confident.
所以，你知道，这才是最重要的。我有1.16万粉丝。我现在已经稳稳领先JF了。JF在任何情况下都不可能追上我。他只有1.02万粉丝。这话可不能乱说。我很自信。我非常自信。
I mean, you have a lot of decades ahead of you you don't think there's any any scenario that plays out that he you know no he ends up ahead jf has kids jf has two children he does not he does not have as much free time to are you not gonna have kids at some point like like i'm so confident like i'm not even worried about jf like like listening to this podcast because i know he doesn't have time in his life to be listening to this podcast jf buddy if you are listening you should text me and tell me that i'm wrong i feel like someone's just gonna dm him now and say hey you should listen to this episode but that's assuming that
我的意思是，你前面还有好几十年呢，你真的觉得没有任何剧本会让他……不，他最后会领先。JF有孩子了，JF有两个孩子，他没有那么多空闲时间去……难道你以后不打算要孩子吗？就像……我太自信了，我甚至都不担心JF会听到这个播客，因为我知道他生活中根本没时间听这个播客。JF，老兄，如果你在听，你应该给我发短信告诉我我错了。我觉得有人现在就会直接私信他，说：“嘿，你应该听听这一集。”但这假设了
he's going to get that he's going to have time to see the dm and then like he's going to follow through on listening to the episode that's not going to happen for for those that haven't been listening since episode zero just so everyone knows bryce is very good friends with jf and he is a host of a rival podcast okay you can't call them a rival podcast because they put out like two episodes it's a juicy content here bryce bryce is there anything else you'd like to say about jf while we're on the top i'm sure i'm sure tlb hit is very good um they have produced four episodes. How many have we produced? It's not nice to dunk this hard.
他会看到那条私信，并且有时间看，然后还会去听那一期节目——这是不可能发生的。对于那些从第0期开始就没听过的听众，为了让大家知道，布莱斯（Bryce）和JF是非常好的朋友，而且他是竞争对手播客的主持人。好吧，你不能叫他们竞争对手播客，因为他们只推出了两期节目。这里有劲爆的内容，布莱斯，布莱斯，趁我们在聊这个话题，关于JF你还有什么想说的吗？我确信，我确信TLB Hit非常棒……他们已经制作了四期节目。我们制作了多少期？这样狠狠地踩别人可不太好。
This is episode 72. But the two hosts of TLB have children. God, what are we going to do when we have children? I don't know. I don't know. Yeah, you know, I don't know. I'm getting old, man. Yeah, we are getting old.
这是第72期。但TLB的两个主持人都有孩子。天哪，等我们有了孩子该怎么办？我不知道。我不知道。是的，你知道，我不知道。我老了，伙计。是的，我们老了。
We are getting old. So the probability that that's going to end up happening decreases as every day goes by. All right, on that note. You're like 30. You're like 30. You're still there. I'm like, I hope that we have some. If you've made it this far in the podcast,
我们老了。所以随着每一天过去，那种情况最终发生的概率都在下降。好吧，说到这里。你才30岁左右。你才30岁左右。你还在那儿呢。我就想，我希望我们有一些……如果你能把这个播客听到这里，
we're just really going to open up right now. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们现在真的要敞开心扉了。感谢收听，希望你喜欢，祝你拥有美好的一天。本期节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。